getting to where we are familiar with
the language with the intonation with
the pronunciation with the word choices
this is all part of learning the
language it's all part of our brains
getting used to the language hi there
steve kaufman here and today i want to
talk a little philosophically about
language learning i want to talk about
how we get to know a language how we
become familiar with the language
not necessarily how we learn the
language because that's a big part of
learning the language so remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
um
click on the bell for notifications and
of course if you follow me on
uh any of the podcast
websites then please leave a
you know a review
so
you know i like to talk here about
language learning i know that many of my
videos are used by people who are
learning english
uh so i try to speak clearly
uh i think my canadian accent is
somewhat neutral so it's probably easy
for people to understand
and i talk about language learning
because
i want to encourage people to learn
languages and i want to sort of
uh make language learning seem less of a
difficult thing to do
i think if you follow these videos
you'll know that i i sort of
encourage people to treat language
learning as sort of a natural activity
something that if we put in enough time
we will improve
uh we don't have to get everything right
we don't have to get a big you know a
high score on the test we can
as i do try to avoid tests try to avoid
drills exercises try to just learn the
language and a big part of that is this
sense of becoming familiar with the
language so that the language becomes
like a friend so you get to know the
language just like you get to know
you get very familiar with people in
your family familiar family you get to
know your friends you know get another
characteristics um
when you see them
you know how they behave you know what
their character is like so you become
very sort of intimately connected with
them
and i
feel the same way with the languages
that i've learned
maybe it's because i do a lot of
listening so
you know i'm not deliberately trying to
learn anything i do when i'm you know
after listening i i review it on my ipad
and look up words and stuff but i'm not
deliberately trying to learn anything
i'm more trying to
become friends with the language and try
to
start to get in the mood
to enjoy the language and i think
that helps in terms of
pronunciation for example in terms of
intonation in terms of using the right
phrasing
as we start to become familiar with the
language even if we don't fully
understand it a lot of these things are
kind of
penetrating us i noticed this in my
arabic and my and my persian
uh now
paradoxically and and remember again
that many of you are studying languages
at school or you may be studying them
for professional reasons which was my
case when i was learning chinese 50
years ago that was my job i was doing it
seven hours a day but now i'm doing it
as a hobby
i'm doing it out of interest
i'm doing it because i'm interested not
only in the language but in the history
and the culture behind that language and
possibly travel and food and meeting
people and that whole
sense of being able to participate in
another
cultural media
so that's what motivates me
and what i found recently is that
my strategy of
you know and this is this whole issue of
studying more than one language say two
languages at the same time
you know what's the best way to combine
languages should we be doing two
languages the same day or alternating
days
and i'm beginning to find that if i go
one week on one and one week on the
other
then when i come back to the first one
i'm sort of reconnecting with an old
friend
and that's a nice feeling and i'm even
finding and as i said before this
business of benign neglect if you leave
one language go to the other one for a
while come back to the first one all of
a sudden things are clearer
maybe because you've pushed your brain
to work this other language
and maybe because if we stay with the
one language and we're trying to learn
it and we're disappointed that we're not
doing better in a certain amount of
fresh frustration
creeps in whereas if we leave it for a
while do this other language and then we
come back to the first one we rediscover
an old friend everything is fresh again
and
i do find that i hear things more
clearly
i'm a little more aware of of of the
language
and
getting to where we are familiar with
the language with the intonation with
the pronunciation with the word choices
this is all part of learning the
language it's all part of our brains
getting used to the language
and
if we can develop this sort of natural
getting to know the language we're going
to speak more naturally as opposed to
trying to learn it through rules and
and tests and and things of that nature
and it's surprising i i was uh spent a
while with with uh persian then i
started listening to my uh arabic uh
podcasts again and
and and i find that you know i i
recognize my old friend i recognize some
of the personality of the arab speaker
he's sort of very intent on getting his
view across and he uses certain
expressions
in the uh certainly in the uh in the
standard arabic which i'm listening to
from you know these political podcasts
uh the
egyptian arabic has a different
personality and i have a very good tutor
who's creating content for me in
egyptian arabic and so i can get
familiar with and and get to know and
get to feel the personality of egyptian
arabic
and then i'll leave that and then i'll
go to
my persian again and on each of these
occasions
it's staying fresh for me and then i'm
rediscovering an old friend picking up
where we left off
and i find that i'm
progressing perhaps or enjoying it more
or less frustrated by my lack of
progress and more aware
that i am
becoming more familiar with the language
it's becoming more familiar to me it's
becoming more of a friend to me i'm
recognizing characteristics and
therefore intonation pronunciation in
terms of phrases and in that way the
language is gradually penetrating my
brain
and this normally and i found this
when after an absence i started speaking
again with with my tutor
all of a sudden all of this familiarity
this comfort level with the language is
being
you know converts itself into being able
to speak more freely and speak more
i wouldn't say fluently yet in those
languages but more comfortably in those
languages so
you know learning languages is not just
learning rules
although it can help to review the basic
patterns of a language
it's it's becoming you know
emotionally connected to the language
becoming
more familiar with the language making
the language your friend
so
i find the strategy of alternating
languages works for me
but some people may prefer to stay with
one language but ultimately we want to
sort of get that language in you
and so i think learning a language
includes this sense of making these
languages your friend making them
familiar to you so a little bit of a
vague thought but it's something that's
been running around in in my mind and i
i'd be interested in in any reaction
maybe what i had to say there is is just
a lot of nonsense i don't know anyway
thanks for listening